The interesting thing about slices is that they can be determined automatically.
That is, a slicing tool can automatically determine
backward slices of individual statements
and forward slices of individual statements.
Such static slicing tools, therefore, can help you focus
on specific parts of the program,
telling you the possible influences either off a statement
or the possible influences towards a statement.
Such slices become even more interesting, though,
when we apply them not only to programs
but to actual executions.
These are then called dynamic slices.
These apply to executions instead of programs.
That is, rather than reasoning in a program
where a value came from,
you look at the actual execution, typically the failing execution,
and therefore not only know what could have happened
but actually see what has happened.
The base of a dynamic slice is not the program but a trace instead.
A trace lists the statements in the program in the order in which they were executed.
So, if line 3, for instance, was executed 4 times in a row,
then the trace will contain line 3 four times
followed by line 4, followed by line 5,
and possibly going back to line 3 in case there's a loop.
Within the trace, we can now look again at dependencies.
That is, looking at which variables have been read
and which variables have been written.
And if we find, say, that at the bottom of the trace
some variable is wrong,
we can now trace back the dependencies in the execution
and again use this as a base for debugging
when following back the cause-effect chain through the program.
The first thing we need for this is a trace.
Let me show you how to get traces for Python programs.
So here, again, we have our original remove HTML markup function,
and what I've written down here is, again, a tracing function
which accesses the file name of the code
as well as the current line number that's executed,
and we print this out on standard output.
We record this as our tracing function.
Let's use the "buggy" version of the remove HTML markup function here
in order to have some more fun,
and we feed it with this very simple input, just 2 characters,
double quote and less-than sign, which should expose the error.
If we go and execute this,
then we should be able to see the sequence of lines as they're executed.
And we click on Run.
What we see here is that first line 4 was executed,
then line 6, then line 9, then line 11,
line 13, line 14, and this is how we progress through the program execution.
Now for a bit of programming exercise.
Complete the program which you've just seen
such that it prints out the actual code lines
instead of just the file name and number.
That is, replace the output of file name and number
by the actual code line that is in that file at this position.